الليلة الماضية نتنياهو غرد ثم
حذف تدوينة أه اتهم فيها الجيش الإسرائيلي
والشينب رئيس المخابرات لعدم
تحذيره من هجوم 7 أكتوبر
أه ثم أه تعرض للانتقاد قام
بحذف التغريدة واعتذر
وهذا ليس أمرا شائعا
نتنياهو ليفعل ما كان
فكرته الأولى عندما رأيت أن نتنياهو ألقى
اللوم على الجيش الإسرائيلي والشين بات يجب أه أن
نشير لجمهورنا أم أن
نتنياهو لم يقبل حقًا أي
لوم على ما حدث في 7 أكتوبر
على الرغم من أن معظم القادة الكبار  أه
في حكومته وفي جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
قبلوا نصيبهم من
اللوم لا ترون أن السابع من
أكتوبر كان فشلا ذريعا وأساسا
ثلاثة إخفاقات متتالية كل
النجوم اصطفت ضد إسرائيل مما
تسبب في الكارثة فشل استخباراتها
فشل عملياتي
وقيادة سياسية فاشلة، لذلك قال رئيس
المخابرات ورئيس
الجيش إنهم يتحملون
المسؤولية لكنهم يتطلعون للفوز في
هذه الحرب.
رئيس الوزراء
لم يقبل
مسؤوليته وبطريقة ما بدأ
حملة من نوع ما  ح لإلقاء كل اللوم
على الاثنين الآخرين، هذا أمر غير مقبول،
أنا سعيد لأنه اعتذر لأنه فهم
الخطأ والهدف الآن هو كسب
الحرب لتدمير حماس وإعادة
جميع الرهائن من
غزة
نيويورك تايمز  يفيد بأن
شين بيت أم رأى نشاطًا غير عادي من قبل
حماس في الساعات الأولى من يوم 7 أكتوبر،
لكنه لم يعتقد أن هذا النشاط غير العادي
يستدعي إيقاظ رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو. خذنا إلى داخل كيف
تعتقد أنه كان من الممكن إصدار الحكم
بأن هذا النشاط لن يحدث.  لقد كانت
مشكلة كبيرة
لا أعتقد أن أه هذه الأحداث تم
التحقيق فيها واستخلاص المعلومات منها
بالفعل وجهنا للأمام ح سنقوم ح
في نهاية الحرب انظر وفي
كل خطأ تم ارتكابه أولاً لنرى من
نلومه لكن  وأكثر من ذلك للتعلم
واستخلاص المعلومات من أن ذلك لن يحدث
مرة أخرى أبدًا،
أحد الأخطاء الأخرى الواضحة
كان في العلن وهو أن
نتنياهو كان يركز بشدة على
التأكد من تقسيم الفلسطينيين بين
السلطة الفلسطينية في
الضفة الغربية وحماس.  في
غزة، لأنه لم يكن يريد أن
تكون هناك دولة فلسطينية، فقد
دعم حماس في الحصول على الأموال من
قطر، وأعتقد أنه من الواضح أنه كان أكثر
تركيزًا على إيران وحزب
الله وأبعد عينه
عن
حماس وأم أنا  أتساءل عما إذا كنت تعتقد أن
هذه
الحسابات السياسية كانت مجرد
أخطاء صادقة أو أنها كانت
حسابات سياسية خاطئة متجذرة في
شيء
آخر، فقد وجدت السياسة ضد حماس
أنها خطأ فادح ولكن
السياسة ضد حماس كان النموذج هو
أن حماس هي
نظام مسؤول للطوارئ في  غزة، سنير
يهتم بشعبه البالغ عدده مليوني نسمة، وهو
مسؤول عنهم، ويريد أن
يرتفع مستوى معيشتهم، ويريد أن
يبني غزة، وكان هذا خطأً، لقد
كان إرهابيًا، وظل إرهابيًا،
ولا يهتم بالـ 2  مليون شخص
وهو خطط لهذا البرنامج أه في
إسرائيل بدلاً من الاهتمام
بشعب غزة هذا الخطأ ليس
من رئيس الوزراء فقط بل ذهب إلى جميع
رؤساء الوزراء السابقين رئيس
الشنب رئيس جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي ح ال  كان
خطأ رئيس الوزراء هو أنه
لتجنب إجراء عملية جزئية مع
السلطة الفلسطينية، فهو لا
يعتبر حماس رادعًا فحسب، بل كما
قلت في سؤالك، فهو يزودهم
بالأموال القطرية ويمتلك كل
المواد التي تساعدهم على إنتاج جيش
عسكري.  القوة على حدود إسرائيل
تتعارض مع اتفاق أوسلو
ورئيس الوزراء رابين يعد جميع
الإسرائيليين بأنه إذا كان هناك
فلسطينيون، ستكون هناك
سلطة أو دولة أو كيان فلسطيني، وستكون
منزوعة السلاح وما ستفعله إسرائيل
الآن  هو تجريد
شارع غزة من السلاح. الخطأ الثاني للسيد ناني هو
التسعة أشهر التي دفع فيها
إسرائيل إلى أزمة داخلية، حيث
كان الجميع منشغلين بإصلاحه القضائي
بدلاً من أن يكونوا مستعدين لتسببه
بطريقة ما في انخفاض في السلطة القضائية.  ردع
إسرائيل يضعف ردع إسرائيل
مما أدى للأسف إلى هذا الهجوم
من بين أسباب أخرى